[Music]
New Jersey has a severe pension crisis
the unfunded liabilities for pensions is
95 billion dollars the entire New Jersey
state budget is 35 billion dollars New
Jersey does not have the money to pay
for these pensions how did New Jersey
get into the situation the simple answer
is that it is a direct result of the
enormous political power of the New
Jersey Education Association the state's
largest teachers union over the course
of the last 20 years
NJEA has spent over eight hundred
million dollars on its various political
tools with that kind of money
NJEA got what it wanted on pensions
recently NJEA sought to enshrine this
bankrupt system in the state
constitution senate president steve
sweeney stood up to NJEA and JEA then
exacting revenge by vowing to support
Senator Sweeney's opponent in the
Democratic gubernatorial primary and
forcing Sweeney to withdraw from the
race now NJEA has a politician who will
do its bidding
thus encapsulating the New Jersey
pension crisis I'd like to know what you
think about New Jersey's pension crisis
let us know in the comments section and
also let us know what other topics you
want a AEI scholars to cover in 60
seconds